i was recently made
aware of a video that brother abdul
rahman hassan had made
on the permissibility of football or
lack thereof
and this video i found it astounding
absolutely astounding
and i've just come to the conclusion
that there must be a deeper reason
why such conclusions are being met so
after i've
done the initial prognosis if you want
to call it that or diagnostic
and once we've quickly just ran through
some of the things that he said
um i'm going to offer some solutions
insha'allah okay i'm going to offer some
solutions
so the first thing he said was that the
reason why
football well well he was saying about
football that
it has in it allah
laws which are man-made laws against the
against against the laws
of islam let's take a look at this
astonishing and shocking
okay segment of him speaking
about this
[Music]
let's not take it to the because some of
its forms can be
some of his forms can be mentioned
okay we know in our legislation what we
have in our sharia we have
in our 50 books if you look at it when
the scholars speak about
they divide it into four or even if you
want say two let's make it four 4.
act of worship and by that
then we have uh illness
then you have an
ayat are crimes that are committed
and then which are capital punishments
okay i mean punishment for those
scholars that's what our our legal
islamic
legislation revolves around it talks
about after these are the things you
study
now football consists of
it's a game of coming into contact with
one another yeah
okay when a person attacks another
person and breaks a person's bones
or breaks a person's leg or a person
gets injured
or a person's puts a finger in a
person's eye do they go to the chapters
but in our religion we have it doesn't
matter whether it's a game or not islam
as you mentioned in the beginning islam
governs everything it conforms to
everything our religion enters
every minute thing you go to the toilet
you're told how to clean yourself
i'm absolutely astounded by that
because here the obviously the
assumption let's let's say why
is wrong okay the assumption is
that for example they're playing
football and
someone gets injured to the point where
one of the limbs gets amputated which
really happens
well okay their bones get broken which
sometimes does happen
right that the punishment
is going to be automatic removal of the
game red card or whatever it is
and he says that this goes against the
islamic laws
which indicate that you know whatever is
have to be given basically
which you can see in the kotabuf in the
blab of ginayet
how pathetic sorry how is that a
contradiction
when if it's an islamic state the the
person the claimant can actually still
make the claim
and he'll have video evidence to suggest
that the person actually hurt them
if anything football if it's being
recorded
will help the retribution of justice if
that particular court decides to take
videographic evidence
i don't see how there is a mukhalik
and why is it assumed that a referee
should have
i think about this for a second why
should the referee have
the powers to do
or punishments or tajirat whatever maybe
just think before you speak just
think this is absolutely diabolical
this is absolutely different
well he talks about not getting along
with or not
loving not being able to love a people
of different faiths
and religion let's take a look at what
he has to say
the middle like who's offside without
any penalty where it's shot from all of
these are
administrative this is fine we're
talking about
the goal against the laws of allah which
the football players are forced to
follow
for example some of them and i'm going
to expand on some of them for example
some of the laws that yami that they go
into
is um
the player is made to love his football
player team member
even if he's of different religion
this doesn't have to question how are
you playing with you how are you playing
just like your colleague you're at work
you've got a non-muslim colleague
doesn't have to love you work together
of course you're working it's a job for
them
they've some of them even come out
saying we don't get along with the job
years later had
big rifts you didn't raise these two
guys okay i'm really agreeing with you
two or three people he might not get
along with no problem
but he can't get along with the entire
team members
what you've mentioned no different to me
in my corporate job in my company
i've got non-muslims i have to work with
them i'm like some of them i don't know
it's not a lot you can come into your
work and do your work and leave
it's got nothing to do you know i never
know you for your tea your team members
and your people you're working with here
it's a team thing
i need to know who the striker is i the
goalkeeper needs to know the
you have to be no i don't agree with
this point you're part of a
happens when a muslim marries a
christian or a jew
what happened with the prophet muhammad
that's not relating to the religion
natural love between
people from different faiths is haram
then the prophet fell into haram we will
see
how your methodologies and how your
statements
are so totally against the sun and the
quran
that i'm shocked with all due respect
that you had the absolute audacity to
come out and speak in the manner that
you have
on a topic like this
that you may say about allah which you
don't even know
what and i'm shocked that someone who's
spent so much time
i'm actually i can't hold it in and i'm
not going to lie to anyone here
i don't back back this man behind his
back i'm gonna tell you guys
exactly what i think this shows with all
due respect
the difference the important difference
between someone who studies
and regurgitates and memorizes knowledge
and someone who thinks and contemplates
there's no better kind of example we can
get for this
how can you come to these conclusions
how can you praising disbelievers
and he is indicating that
well look he's not saying i'm not going
to go into the permissibility of it or
lack thereof
he says what i am going to say is i
can't see how someone can bring
themselves
to praise someone who basically is a
disbeliever and he
he mentions a few traits so let's see
what he says on this matter
and come back that's something for the
women
men i'm imitating the women in this
writer
i'm sorry to go back to something we
were discussing earlier you mentioned
the hadith to me yesterday which i
i'd like to bring forward in sha allah
we're talking about the way
not we look up to or some of the muslims
look up to
non-muslim footballers and things like
that are you allowed to praise and
almost say he's so good at football
discussion back and forth
don't say
you're not allowed to praise him and
speak highly of him so if the hadith
there's is lot of back and forth to it
but the point is the point is
i don't want to fall i don't want to
press my arsenal on that
i'm saying even if there was a
prohibition on this issue i can't
someone who said allah hasn't got a
child
allah has a child sorry someone who
doesn't believe in allah's existence
somebody who doesn't even worship allah
who disobeys allah after he created him
aborts
into this world i honestly can't speak
greatly and highly and glorify him like
that i can't
my heart won't allow me if someone says
insult with your mother you're a mother
you wouldn't
you wouldn't even dismiss your mother's
value yeah or you would you wouldn't you
wouldn't like him in any way shape or
form
you have enmity towards him what about
allah i know you're saying this guy's
such a good player i want to watch him i
like the way he plays
also the concept
now this is absolutely diabolical
and this is muhalfali sunnah he is
mentioning a hadith which he says oh the
authenticity of it is
we don't know whether it's strong or
weak well let me give you three hadith
which we know
the authenticity is strong number one
ibnadi who the prophet muhammad
explicitly absolutely explicitly said
had he been alive i would have had i
would have forgiven this i would have
asked allah to forgive these people
so this is a kind of praise but he might
say no you must you know
you guys mention the philosophers why
you mention the philosophers when you
have quran sunnah
why are you mentioning the you know the
thinkers and so
why are you mentioning aristotle why
mentioning plato
well i want to tell you something today
that maybe you did not know
that the prophet muhammed he mentioned a
bait
of shar he mentioned the line of shah
from a man called
who was a non-believer before the time
of islam and he mentioned
or something to this effect that
whatever is aside allah is in vain
and that the prophet muhammed
this is the truest thing a prophet a
poet has said
why am i even mention it if there's no
utility value and so doing
why even mention us
he praised the romans he said that the
quickest to recover he actually
mentioned so many characteristics
he said that the quickest to recover
after a defeat
one of the things that he mentioned of
many things so you can't bring yourself
to praise disbelievers
but the prophet muhammad
could either you are better than them or
you don't understand
them and you don't understand the
religion fully and this is why i
want to offer my services i don't want
to just tell you i don't mean this to
allah who are not trying to arrogate to
you
i just don't want to backfire you i want
to say this so everyone can hear it and
i want to say to friends and family oh
look at this guy he doesn't know this
and doesn't know that
i'm making fun of you behind your back
i'd rather you see this and make it
public
but i do want to offer my services yeah
i think that was due is like a crash
course in critical thinking and
i think that if we humble each other
ourselves to each other
maybe we can teach each other certain
things
the two kinds of people don't learn the
knowledge shy person and an arrogant
person
i would say please take my offer up we
work closely with you
okay to try and develop critical
reasoning skills
and hopefully you can start applying
those
any photos